in this video of USMLE step one high
heel series we will learn about the
acute cholecystitis acute cholecystitis
is a progressive distension inflammation
and infection of gallbladder
this occurs due to prolonged blockage of
the cystic duct by a gallstone
a rare variant is known as a calculus
cholecystitis where there is no
gallstones but it occurs in chronically
debilitated or critically ill patients
let's understand the clinical picture of
acute cholecystitis or acute coli as we
see it
the patient presents with nausea and
vomiting right upper quadrant abdominal
pain and fever on examination you get
right upper quadrant tenderness a very
famous sign which is Murphy's Sign which
is actually inspiratory arrest with deep
right upper quadrant palpation and low
grid fever while measured
we diagnose acute cholecystitis based on
Radiology the first choice is a USG of
whole or upper abdomen in that we get to
see a thickened gallbladder wall
presence of stone or sand within the
gallbladder Lumen and a pericholasistic
fluid collection all these three points
Point towards acute cholecystitis
a more advanced nuclear medicine Imaging
is HIDA scan where non-visualization of
gallbladder in the scan images indicate
towards acute cholecystitis
once we have diagnosed acute choline we
treat acute Coley
in the following manner the conservative
approach includes broad spectrum IV
antibiotics IV fluids and Pain
Management the definitive treatment is
obviously cholecystectomy which can be
either open cholecystectomy where you
cut open the abdomen with a broad
incision or it can be a laparoscopic
cholecystectomy where you do a
more conservative and micro surgery
I hope you have understood the video
well if you have understood this video
you can follow us on our Facebook page
on Instagram to get high quality
flashcards and notes
also you can support our channel so that
we can continue to provide you with high
quality content for free using a super
thanks where you can pay using paytm
PayPal or UPI also you can support us
via our patreon page
if you want to connect you you have all
the links of urban in the description
box below and for medicine related
content you are supposed to follow the
nerd medic until then bye bye see you in
the next one